- I don't think in my
life I've turned redder.
- (bleep) Why.
- This is my worst texting
experience I've ever had.
So when I was in high
school, I was dating this guy
that I thought I was into,
but then New Years Eve
was rolling around and we
had planned this whole party
with my friend who was
also dating his friend
and it was this whole thing.
And I realized like right
before New Years Eve
that I didn't really like him anymore.
And I was texting my friend
about it and how I was
planning on breaking up
with him and how annoyed
with him I was, while I
was sitting next to him.
And I thought I was texting my friend
but he all of a sudden got
this text and he looked
at his phone and then he looked at me.
And I was like, "What?"
And he was like "What the (bleep)?"
And I was like, "What? I don't know.
Like, I don't have your phone."
And he was like, "You
just sent me that text."
And I was like, "What text?"
And I started to panic a little bit,
and I was like, "Oh my God, oh my God."
So I looked at my phone, and sure enough
I hadn't texted my friend
the 10 page thing about
how annoyed with him I was,
I had texted it to him.
We still went to the party.
We had fun, but we broke
up a couple days later
to no one's surprise.
- So I'm like really bad at
saving numbers in my phone.
There's a lot of people in
my text messages that just
don't have saved numbers, and I just don't
always know who's texting me.
So there's this one time
that I had this big crush
on this guy and he had a 310 number
or something like that, and
all of a sudden, one day
he asked me to go to his DJ
show up in North Hollywood.
I'm like, "Oh my God,
oh my God, he likes me.
He wants me to go to his DJ show.
Oh my God, oh my God, I should go!"
Basically, this place is far.
This place is so far, and I'm
driving for love, you know?
For potential love, and so I
get there and it's like this
weird bar, and I'm like,
okay, I'll find him.
So I'm looking around for
him, and then I see this guy
that I know, and basically
he's this creepy guy
whose number I got a long time
ago and he kept wanting me
to hang out with him, and
he's DJing that night.
And so I'm just like why is he
DJing here? What's going on?
And then I'm like, (bleep).
And so I look at my phone and I realize
that he was the one texting me.
Creepy dude was texting
me, not crush dude.
It was actually creepy dude.
And so now, creepy dude thinks that
I'm so into him that I
would drive all the way
to his DJ set just to hang out with him.
You know, you'd think I'd
learn from that, but I don't.
- So probably about three or
four years after I graduated
college, I was working in
New York City, I was having
a steady job, feeling great about life.
And, you know, Facebook was
the way you communicated
with a lot of people back in college.
And so I went on a limb and
I was talking to this girl.
Like, "Hey, I see you're
in New York City."
She just graduated about
a year or so before.
I was like, "We should meet up for a drink
or grab some dinner or something."
She wrote back, she's like,
"Hey, I would love to.
I actually work in Midtown,"
which is where I work.
Like, "Great let's just go,
grab some dinner after work."
She was like, "Fantastic."
I didn't want to think it was a date,
we didn't call it anything.
It was just like hanging out,
but I was just so excited
to be hanging one-on-one.
We've always vibed, we've
always had good conversations
in college, but I was always too afraid
to ask her out, or I was
always dating someone
or she was always dating someone.
So just never the opportunity arose.
I told a couple of my friends
I was going out with her.
Some of my friends that went
to college with us as well.
They were texting me throughout the night
and this is before even iPhones.
This is just like regular
old school Nokia phones,
you have to press like two three times
to get to B or C and stuff like that.
And so I'm texting her,
she went to the bathroom.
I text some friends like,
"Yeah, it's going well.
We're just having good conversation."
I'm not stressing about it.
Couple drinks go down, and
so I just pick up my phone,
I start texting my friends.
I'm like, "I can't believe I'm
hanging out with this girl.
She's so (bleep) beautiful.
I hope something happens."
I can't remember the exact text,
but I just remember saying
she is so (bleep) beautiful.
And her phone vibrates, and she goes,
"Sorry, it might be my friend."
She opens up the phone,
and it's a text from me.
I texted her I can't believe
how (bleep) beautiful she is.
Like, I'm so happy to be
on this date right now.
And she looks at me, and she goes, "Huh."
And I go, "What? Is everything alright?"
She goes, "Yeah, but
did you mean to text me
how beautiful I was?"
I don't think in my
life I've turned redder.
Like a full shade of dark red,
almost like I was choking.
Like I needed the Heimlech
Maneuver at the restaurant.
And she was like, "It's
cute, I appreciate it.
But you know, I thought this
was just like a friend thing."
and I was just like,
"Totally is, I'm just dru--"
Like, you know, when
you're so embarrassed,
you make up every excuse in the book?
And I couldn't even come
up with an idea of like,
"Oh, I was texting about some other girl,"
because I was literally
sitting in front of her,
it was in present conversation.
So we're still friends, we
talk every once in a while.
- [Interviewer] Amazing.
- Hey guys, we're Peralide.
Did you know it's Hispanic Heritage Month?
- (speaking foreign language)
- For more Latino content,
- subscribe here.